Speaker 1: This is just unbelievable. There's
now a picture. Of the top secret documents that
Trump had at Mar a Lago. And every detail is
insane, including the crass, cheesy casino
style carpets that Trump seems to love everywhere
in his residence. But we're going to get to that.
Remember the shifting narratives? We didn't have
any documents. If there were documents there,
the FBI planted them well. But they weren't
classified. But they weren't secret.
Well, they were, but I declassified them. They're
back to. They were planted. We'll get to that
tomorrow. On and on and on. But all along, sowing
doubt. We now have the pictures and it's wild. And
there is reason to believe, per the feds, now
that the Trump Circle was specifically trying
to obstruct the investigation by moving documents
around. You just have to see this to believe it.
So first report Associated Press Feds Side Efforts
to obstruct Probe of Documents at Trump Estate.
The Justice Department says classified documents
were likely concealed and removed from a storage
room at former President Donald Trump's Florida
state as part of an effort to obstruct the federal
investigation into the discovery of the government
records. So understand the meaning of that.
Okay. The Trump people were insisting when
they asked us for the documents in June,
we gave them to them when they told us to put a
lock on the door. We put a lock on the door. We
then get the affidavit and there's nothing about
a lock. The entire lock thing was just fabricated,
as based on what we know right now. Nobody ever
said everything's cool. As long as you put a lock
on the door, a padlock, if you can imagine.
So that ends up being a lie. And then also,
of course, the idea that they gave all the
documents back is what is obviously debunked
by this picture, which we were putting up on the
screen for you. And if you look at this picture,
you see all sorts of documents, some in
very, very large letters marked secret or
top secret. And they are on the floor of Trump's
office. You can see some framed Time magazine
covers on the right side of the image. And then
you see these just the casino rugs. You know,
it's a reminder that money can't buy you class.
The fact that Donald Trump puts literal casino
rugs in his office or bedroom or around his
toilet, wherever, whatever it is that that this is
this is absolutely extraordinary. Absolutely
extraordinary. And the report is that federal
prosecutors believe that certain pages of the
records were actually torn up. Now, if that
is true for a normal person, you would be barred
from ever holding public office ever again in the
United States. Unfortunately, that's not really
enough. Prison is what is deserved. Remember
reality winner who ended up with I don't want to
Miss State, but was it was it four or five years
for one page that we're talking about one
page? This is just pages upon pages upon pages.
Any one of which could could dump people in prison
just for a single one. And it's just page after
page with prosecutors believing that some of these
were torn up. So there should be prison time. I'm
not making a prediction that there will be, but
there should be prison time here. And then we,
of course, have to go back to what was the
point of having these documents. And speculation
is quite a broad about what they were there
for. Is it that it was a way for Trump to
stroke his own ego, to show visitors, hey, look
at what I've got here. I've got the latest was
documents on Emmanuel Macron's sex life or
whatever. Not that those would necessarily be the
most, most classified. But putting that aside, was
it to stroke his ego by showing them to people?
I mean, did he plan to sell them at some point,
which is a whole other crazy thing. And it's
speculative, of course. One thing I'm increasingly
thinking is that law enforcement has not yet
even recovered all of the documents that they're
aware Trump had at one point. It seems to me,
particularly with this paragraph, about there's
a belief some documents, some pages were torn
up. And why the hell would some of them be torn up
again? We can only speculate about why that would
be. My guess is part of the reason that this is
all happening is the FBI still to this day, as we
are about to start September of 2022, doesn't
actually have knowledge of the whereabouts of
every single one of these documents. So as far as
prison. Someone must be heading to prison. I don't
expect it to be Trump. But could this end up being
it's all an oopsie and no one is going to prison
at all for the increasingly egregious violations
that we are learning about taking place here?
It it it would be stunning if that were the case,
and the picture is just too much. Now, initially,
it was believed or reported that the documents
splayed all over the floor was how they were
found by the FBI. That appears not to be the case.
It seems as though they were placed on the floor
with an exhibit number in order to be photographed
by the FBI, but that they were not actually found
in that state if they were. That's even crazier.
Like Trump's just storing them all over the floor.
Stranger things have happened, but it
doesn't actually appear that that's the case.
And one growing source of trouble and strife
for Donald Trump is that this entire search
warrant situation, Trump is not having his
legal fees paid by the Republican National
Committee anymore. And that's a big problem for
Trump. And we're going to talk about that next.